[Aplausos]
y
como un soplo de aire fresco para los
ciudadanos ucranianos sumidos en guerra
con rusia así se celebró la victoria del
grupo la lucha orchestra en el concurso
de eurovisión de este año en la ciudad
italiana de turín cada pequeña victoria
es importante para cada okra nyan o para
nuestra ucrania para cada uno de
nosotros los ucranianos lograron ganar
con una canción que fusiona el rap con
la música folklórica
[Música]
dedicada a la madre del vocalista del
grupo y es que el asedio que está
sufriendo ucrania la convirtió en la
clara favorita de esta edición con un
récord de votación del público a su
favor y felicitaciones por parte de la
comunidad internacional y otros
organismos como la otan
we need your decision context me
gustaría felicitar a ucrania por haber
ganado el concurso de eurovisión y no lo
hago a la ligera porque ayer vimos el
inmenso apoyo del público en toda europa
y australia
publix port all over europe
tradicionalmente los ganadores acogen el
certamen el año siguiente
algo que ucrania espera poder hacer en
2023 con la esperanza de haber dejado
atrás el conflicto con rusia
nuestro valor impresiona al mundo
nuestra música conquista europa el año
que viene ucrania acogerá el concurso de
eurovisión haremos todo lo posible para
que un día los participantes e invitados
de eurovisión sean recibidos en una
mariupol libre pacífica y reconstruida
no obstante en medio de las
celebraciones tanto el grupo musical
ganador como los políticos ucranianos
aprovecharon para mandar un mensaje
ucrania todavía necesita toda la ayuda
que se le pueda brindar
marín
[Aplausos]